sometimes in the political world when
you are an exception to the rule you get
a lot of attention and oftentimes that
attention can become weaponized for
example most black Americans are pretty
liberal so when someone like Candace
Owens a right-wing black woman
supposedly right-wing I mean I think
it's partially a character she plays but
whatever she presents his right wing she
gets attention she gets a ton of
attention and is able to spread
dangerous misinformation which is
welcomed with open arms by right-wingers
most American Jews are liberal so when
you have a conservative Jew they often
get more attention for their views than
they would if their identity was
different and another example of this is
that Hollywood and actors are
overwhelmingly liberal so when someone
like James Woods the actor who's a right
winger starts sharing right wing talking
points
he gets more attention because partially
of his identity and this is very
dangerous the same applies to college
kids and people just out of college or
people who would be just out of college
if they went but maybe didn't who tend
to be more on the left so when someone
like Charlie Kirk is out there they get
a lot of attention and they can spread
very dangerous disinformation and
case-in-point
over the weekend James Woods and Charlie
Kirk both shared a supposed analysis and
using that term is almost a joke of how
Bernie Sanders would handle taxes and
paying for Medicare for all and it is
riddled with not differences of opinion
which are fine
it's just riddled with disinformation
and unfortunately the posts caught fire
the Trump is love it these have been
shared hundreds of thousands of times
across all the people who have posted
them the graphic that James Woods and
Charlie Kirk shared claims that since
under a Bernie Sanders administration
everybody gets at least 15 bucks an hour
for work that they do anybody working
full-time of course not taking any time
off would earn 30 $1,200 a year at a
minimum and the graphic that's being
being shared goes on to say bernie is
going to pay for Medicare for all by
taxing people making over 29,000 at the
rate of 52 percent now this is
completely wrong
but according to this viral image that
makes the effective after-tax hourly
wage of someone getting paid 15 bucks an
hour and paying 52 percent in taxes
which of course is a lie they end up
only taking home 7 dollars and 20 cents
an hour charlie kirk shared the same
thing with the additional message
socialism sucks added to the bottom now
it's actually difficult to know where to
start with this but it's a good
opportunity to really get a good
understanding of how about--how Bernie's
plan would work on Bernie's tax plan
would work how we'd pay for Medicare for
all now we can have reasonable
fact-based disagreements about Bernie's
Medicare for all plans for example you
could argue I don't believe it's fair to
rich people to do what Bernie wants to
do ok we could debate that that's a
great conversation you could say I don't
think it's fair to poor people or
middle-class people you could say I
think bernie is too optimistic and how
cheap the delivery of health care will
be under his plan great I've made that
critique we can talk about it but we
have to be arguing about the real world
we can't be arguing about these
completely fake disagreements based on
viral right-wing disinformation so let's
dig into it first of all our tax rates
are marginal number one meaning you only
pay the highest rate on income for the
money earned above where that bracket
starts so in Bernie's tax brackets a
single tax payer would pay 52% tax only
on income above ten million dollars a
year so someone earning the thirty one
thousand two hundred dollars mentioned
in this viral image would pay 10 percent
on their first ninety five hundred bucks
and then twelve percent on the amount
they make between ninety five twenty
five and thirty one thousand two hundred
now remember that there is a standard
deduction of twelve thousand two hundred
dollars which would drop the taxable
income for someone earning thirty one to
two just nineteen thousand dollars which
means they'd end up paying a little over
two thousand dollars in taxes they would
then get their additional four percent
for health care on their income based
premium that Bernie has proposed and
this means if you earn thirty
one two you end up with an effective tax
rate of 9.1 percent not 52% and that
includes your payment towards health
care imagine being this financially
illiterate and still having a voice in
the political discussion like James
Woods or Charlie Kirk and the
disinformation being spread argues that
all sorts of people would be paying 52%
tax when in reality the 52% applies only
to incomes above 10 million dollars per
year in 2014 that would have applied to
only 0.02 percent of taxpayers that
number presumably is a little bit higher
in 2020 so there's plenty to debate
about Medicare for all you need the
Senate support aoc recently said Bernie
can't wave a magic wand and make
Medicare for all happened I said it
months ago I was crushed for it
AOC said it she was welcomed mostly with
open arms but she's right and it's a
very real question about Medicare for
all
I believe Bernie's plan understates the
cost of care but Bernie doesn't want
people earning $31,000 to pay 52 percent
income of their income to taxes and they
are either fundamentally ignorant to the
reality of the plan that's one
possibility they just don't get it
or they know that they can't actually
argue against the plan on its merits so
they resort to spreading disinformation
and it works because these bogus numbers
were shared hundreds of thousands of
times by the various people that posted
and reposted and retweeted them we can't
let them control the information in this
way because they are weaponizing the
call it ignorance call it gullibility
call it whatever you want it is being
weaponized
by the American right very successfully
make sure you're following me on Twitter
at D Pakman we'll be back right after
this if you watch the David Pakman show
you should check out a YouTube channel
we're partnering with called
up flip click the link right underneath
this video it'll take you to their
channel while you're there make sure to
subscribe and click that bell for
up flip is a channel perfect for anyone
like me who's fascinated with small
businesses and entrepreneurs and what
makes them tick and every Wednesday up
flip uploads a new video where they
interview an entrepreneur they give you
an inside look at how the business works
what makes the business successful what
a day in their shoes is really like if
you enjoy shows like Shark Tank I think
you'll really like this channel and
again the channel is called up flip
they're friends of the David Pakman show
I'd love it if people in my audience
subscribe to their channel click the
bell so that you get updates about their
videos and I've put a link right below
that will take you directly to their
YouTube channel check it out